[Music]
so uh jerome powell of the fed
is ready to
bring some pain
to households and businesses quote
unquote
these are the unfortunate costs
of reducing inflation
powell said that the market will have to
weaken before inflation be can be
considered under control and these are
the unfortunate
costs of reducing inflation a failure to
restore price stability would mean
greater far greater pain
um but let's roll this up though he's
talking about what the sentence before
he says the u.s labor market why does
the labor market have to go south for
the economy to recover
while higher interest rates slower
growth and softer labor market
conditions will bring down inflation
they will also bring some pain to
households and businesses
brought to you by your government
okay now
here's what's interesting um
god this is so
infuriating
um
the problem is he's wrong
that's the other problem not only is he
is this just
so
much an aristocracy
that talks down their nose to regular
people and i'm going to throw the switch
over here and you poor people are going
to have some pain in your households and
businesses but you're going to like it
but you're going to like me for it yeah
because it gets rid of inflation you
arrogant
yeah
yeah
andy's wrong
it's um
okay so where did this inflation come
from inflation increased in prices okay
we've talked about this on the show
before but let's talk about it again
inflation in this case did not come from
a white hot economy
that the economy just grew and grew and
was too much prosperity god help us
to the point that prices started
shooting up because there was just
too
much good things going on so prices just
go up now that actually happened in the
70s
okay that was real inflation in that
sense the inflation that we had was what
we're calling inflation and it is
inflation it's an increase in prices
was primarily caused by a couple of
things
when you
don't produce goods and services
for a half a year or a year
you create a shortage of those goods and
services
you create a shortage of lumber create a
shortage of automobiles you create a
shortage of almost everything
when you create a shortage of something
100 of the time the prices go up did you
notice toilet paper
you know you create a shortage of it you
create this this
ridiculous urgency to buy
people came out of their houses after
covet and they've been sitting around
looking at their own
grimy house and they said i don't live
in a grimy house anymore i'm going to
buy another house
and they rushed out of their homes like
coming out of the caves like a baptist
after a casserole and went crazy buying
houses and drove house prices up demand
was ridiculous and we saw one of the
highest increases in house prices in a
single year almost ever
in
2020. and i was 20 29 it went up wow
how's price went up shortage
more buyers than sellers
scarcity
it's a supply demand curve they used to
teach it in the seventh grade i don't
think they teach it anymore apparently
they didn't teach it to jerome
so um
but that's what you know drove prices up
it was not a white hot economy it was a
shortage created by
a
fouchy induced quarantine
where we shut everything down remember
when we had to flatten the curve where
we were all going to die it just just
didn't anybody ever come back and go
that was a bunch of bull crap just for
two weeks anybody ever come back and
call bs on that but they never did but
let's just go ahead and remember we had
to flatten the curve where we were all
going to die right and so they shut the
factories down
and you remember then when you had to be
six feet apart but then you didn't
and you remember then when you had to
buy a mask and but you didn't remember
then if you got vaccine you wouldn't get
coveted but then you got covered anyway
you remember all that stuff this all
affected the economy because people
weren't working in producing goods and
services creating a shortage and that
shortage drove prices up it's pent up
demand right exactly
exactly
and so lumber went 3x yeah
and on top of that then you reach over
here to the biden administration and
they say well everybody needs to be
driving electric cars because that's
good for the air quality even though we
know that fossil fuels actually create
the electricity that goes into the car
so it's kind of a problem there but
anyway we're still going to cut off the
fuel
spike it and create a shortage on gas so
now we got five dollar gas at the pump
brought to you by a green policy in the
white house
okay so
inflation at the pump inflation and
housing inflation in
uh supply chain disruptions that's
creating shortages ships and all that
stuff so
interest rates being low
did not cause
this inflation
shortages cost it
we just established that
so interest rates being high
does not fix this inflation it's
exacerbated and suffering to you little
people because that's what you deserve
because you're inflationary people
thank you jerome you arrogant no good
bureaucrat
so i mean seriously
if in if low interest rates did not heat
up the economy and cause this inflation
then it is fairly easy to establish that
high interest rates are not going to
slow down the economy in the way you
want it to the way you slow down the
economy is you get the supply chain
working again and you turn the stupid
green off at the white house and get the
pipeline flowing again and if they
flooded the cert then prices would go
down because there would be a surplus of
lumber and a service
of gasoline bricks and workers you know
what gas was two dollars under trump
it's not because trump's a magician
because all he did was say drill baby
drill yeah that's all he said
it's the exact opposite and there's a
there's a glut a an oversupply of
gasoline well i remember that day there
was one day that prices went down
it went under two dollars and oil went
negative oil went negative everyone went
negative but gas at the pump was under
two dollars yeah does anybody that was
20 minutes ago y'all not remember this
and and no trump can't he'll strut
around take credit for it but he didn't
do it right it was just he let chevron
do their job let exxon do their job
their job is not woke virtue signaling
their job is drill for oil right that's
their job
and they're good at their job by the way
they can produce the crap out of it if
you leave them alone
so so the way you fix inflation when
they're shortages is you help the
companies not you help the companies
under production
not not raise interest rates but these
bozos are raising interest rates and
they're going to slow down the economy
but they're going to slow it down in
ways they don't want to slow it down and
then it's going to be hard to jump start
it again seems like they're going crazy
they're gonna they're it's just gonna
it's just no it's not gonna create a
crash it's just dumber than crap
it's classic keynesian economic
socialism and these guys tinkering mad
men tinkering with the sound board and
buddy they got the sound all off
and arrogant
you arrogant
now they will also bring some pain to
households and businesses
that's your fed talking to you people
america they need their butts fired if
anybody worked for me and acted like
that i'd fire them